on this episode Krewella stops by
you
huh
this is
ask Gary B
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 215 of the
askgaryvee show and this is a fun show
i've got a whole crew with me and I'm in
the vaynermedia LA office as we normally
drill this in New York City I'm thrilled
to be here I'm excited about this
episode I think we actually have similar
backgrounds in to how we got to this
moment so actually let's start with that
vaynernation please why don't you guys
introduce yourself to everybody want to
tell them who you are what you do all
right
I'm Johan I'm you ask me we are Cruella
this is our manager Jake one of our
managers hi so for everybody who's
watching what is Cruella like what what
do you guys do like where'd you guys
come from what kind of music genre like
how do you guys roll we're from Chicago
gotta get that at first like I probably
graduated with Jake this guy is really I
don't we're all from not one I actually
did a little bit of home run before him
did you grow up are you from Chicago or
suburb of Chicago a suburb of Chicago
but we like the city because we
definitely did live there and I'm
freaked by the way on a side note this
is amazingly weird timing I'm obsessed
right now with Chicago ahead oh great
like that like yes but more so chance to
rapper and even I'm obsessed with Sabha
like I think Chicago is like which by
the way this is a weird thing to say
that I want to get like beat up right
now in my own show like I'm I'm
historically pretty disrespectful to
Chicago just doesn't have why I was I
want to be off that divide maybe because
it's a little New York bias and I'm
disrespectful to every city besides in
New York I don't know I'm I'm weird
about Chicago makes me sad to say that
because Brandon Warneke who runs Wine
Library my best friend in the world is a
huge Cubs fan so I have a lot of love
for that I don't know like it's always
windy like I don't know like I don't
know but it gives you thick skin if
you're walking to work every day we're
walking to school and you have this like
brutally cold frozen burn on your
clothes off blowing it your legs
every day you can handle anything
there's some truth of that why don't you
tell everybody a little bit about your
musics I think it's really cool and then
I think we will go into to the questions
know India today so we've got a
substitute but you think you didn't do
it right jab you guys want to go a
little bit more right we are at
electronic dance music artists where
singers songwriters and DJs
we are currently working on our second
follow-up EP to ammunition which we just
released a month ago going on a sweatbox
tour in fall which is a tiny venues like
sweaty punk rock venues and we're
bringing our whole like rock and rave
style there so that's currently what's
happening for us right now
and so when I was doing a little bit of
like actually have there's a lot of fans
at Vayner of your guys work there were
some people that were pretty excited in
New York that were sad to find out the
show was being filmed here for the for
the music enthusiasts out there
I can't ask this off-camera before we
started which I hate doing which is why
I'm bringing it up
what kind of pop for you look how did
you guys hit the scene I think one of
things I'm most fascinated by knowing
there's a lot of entrepreneurs and
business people marketers here I do
think the Internet is the true middleman
I was curious about kind of like I asked
you like when when was your pop moment
when did you guys pop and you kind of
laughed and I laughed because everybody
sees the results and you're like it's
kind of a long journey and my answer was
well of course and I know most people
don't think that you know it's all these
years and years of work like but what
were those moments I thought were the
sites or the blogs or or the moments
within that ecosystem that kind of like
first made it happen for you guys you
actually mentioned this song is sick
before we went on air and they was one
of the first blogs who posted us so it
freaks out when they posted us because
you were fans of it already
oh yeah we trolled their blog like crazy
for new music and to be posted on there
was such a huge deal for us so that we
belonged in that community well Karen
that did I guess I should I love being
transparent like a couple months ago I
bought a very large stake in this song
is set amazing
so main our media did for our publishing
decision actual of those guys and I just
think that they do some of the most
authentic stuff and I totally am so very
cool that's clear and so what about um
what about online video like I've seen
you guys put out several videos they
look really cool and you should have
punished them how did those go for you
guys how does that experience been in
general I think what really giving
attention for us was the kill init video
and it was the first time that people
saw the face for the artists and I think
that identifying was really important
for a fan and seeing what is beyond just
the song that they're listening to and
at the time there weren't artists in the
electronic dance music scene where the
vocalists were actually in the group a
lot of them have been vocalist was a
mystery right so you'd go these
festivals and like download these songs
it would be just the name of the DJ or
producer and they're technically it was
like a ghost singer you would have know
who this singer is the vocalist or the
writer of the song is so we were one of
the first groups at the time who had a
producer in the group who's Chris who
was in the group with us and then yes we
know being a vocalist singers and
songwriters of the group as well and
welcome to perspective like from your
vantage point what if what have you seen
what's been interesting in their rise or
in the marketplace today I just think
they offer something completely
different to the space there is no women
whatsoever on any of these dance music
festivals and Johanna and Yasmine had
this real desire to understand the scene
they wanted to come at it from an
authentic get very different way and
that worked and always works on language
you know what it's really all right
let's get these questions hey what's up
Corolla and Gary via my name's Stephen
Gould there's so many good producers out
there right now getting released on
labels getting uploads on sheepy and
proximity all these channels getting
blog coverage even charting on hype
machine what separates the artists that
get all this promotion and just get a
little bit of royalties here and there
and the artists that actually get to
make a living off with music see anyone
afraid to experiment and I always
appreciate producers when I hear them
who step outside a certain BPM or even
genre I always love first taking
mentality and for me those are the
people that will remember for years and
years and just to name a few like
Skrillex were big fans of Skrillex of
course everything that like Jackie does
it's really cool pegboard nerds were
huge fans of them and who else that's a
discord we love what they do as far as
experimentation I also think that
musicians who are able to create a song
in our EDM world is amazing because you
get so used to be build up then the drop
and the breakdown in the build in the
drop and it just seems so contrived
after a while but you get people like
Calvin Harris who make real songs that
embody so much more than just the built
in the drop and I think that is
incredible I think my answer is going to
be slightly more in the context of how
you guys know that I role which is I
think the I think what separates it is
the market decides you know this whole
notion that like there's so much great
music I mean I think there probably is
and I think some of the great music of
all time was never heard because the
market decided it wasn't great meaning
who gets to decide what is great and I
always find that to be super fascinating
is it an executive who's got an ear like
as a Clive Davis for the years like
absolutely not it's it's the end market
so a lot of you email me and say I've
been doing a daily blog called daily day
and a lot of music has been given to
Dirac for us and we use a lot of n we're
getting hundreds of emails now because
they're getting a lot of exposure from
the people that are watching the YouTube
show and it's helping them so a lot of
people want their music on the show and
everybody writes the same thing which is
this is great my stuff is great
everybody tells me it's great and the
answer is I think it's some level like
the market gets to decide like everybody
wants to think they're great it's almost
like I was think about is the way like
American Idol when it first came out
like those people that in that first
show of every season where they really
liked not the people that were like just
trying to get on TV later but those
first two or three seasons where you
would just genuinely see somebody who
literally thought they
were great right who literally thought
they were great and in that environment
judges got to decide if they moved on I
think what's so fascinating about
today's music marketplace and the
business marketplaces with the internet
being the true middleman whether you go
with soundcloud or blogs pick you up or
you put out YouTube's up or or Vimeo or
whatever you do I think what separates
you know the people that make a living
or not is the paying customer that
enough people decide you are to read
that it allows you to do it for a living
mmm actually think the ones that do it
for Hobby versus of living it's quite
simply 10,000 hours and when you guys
got started it was very different than
what it was four or five years later and
you guys continue to get better do you
think that Malcolm Gladwell like put in
the work but do you really think that do
you'd like for example FX look good by
IU do you think if I put in 10,000 hours
of EDM skills that I could be great at
media so cuz I can tell you right now I
can't it's okay sewing like I genuinely
like the talent has been stripped out of
the equation is it like this there is a
producer both because I can tell you
right now that is just not in me where
is any where is authenticity hasn't been
part of it and that's not authentic to
you well that's right that's right but I
do think the ten pounds now I think is
very bad thing I do think and I talk
about hustle and hard work a lot I just
am surprised that talent is starting to
be in scripted out of the equation like
to be a musician like you guys like you
guys are talented like that's a thing
that's actually Jackie's and I don't
think that I first of all I don't think
that I'm up to par with certain artists
that I look up to and I talked about
like Adele's vocals yeah I was born a
probably the number one singer in the
world have success so I don't think I
was born with this like do you think in
a better voice than they average hundred
people out there no I don't know your
reason over
that is because I think it's in in
Tallinn and today where people think
artists are on this unattainable
pedestal but if you go back to like the
beginning of human human civilization
everyone was sitting in a circle banging
on some drums and singing all together
wasn't this like separate out I like
that everything I don't think I don't
even sing
I just don't think everybody wants to
pay everybody to hear them sing today I
think it's different I think it's its
vision it's your voice it's your
songwriting it's it's how you curate
your YouTube video issue have the issue
with your romantic point of view right
now is it's not being executed in
reality there are hundreds of millions
of people that want to do with there
there's tens of millions of Americans
that want to do what you're doing right
now like and and more interesting Lee
and you guys know this you're the scene
it's much what's happening in
entrepreneurship it's what's happening
in athletics like there are plenty of
people that have put in lots and lots of
hours especially if they come from
affluence where their parents have
allowed them to be able to go to every
[ __ ] lesson 47,000 times
like sometimes talent has to be part of
the equation and hunger see though cuz
you just long as people are giving
everything sure I mean if the morning I
think is a big variable all right before
we start getting really testing your
second question
you
ooh I'm gonna join us in spite of your
hand you don't get those questions after
a show so I think that that's a great
question by Heather I think that rented
land has a negative point of view here
right now in the way that she asked the
question so many people are scared that
they don't own their Facebook page they
don't own their snapchat account but I
don't think people understand is that's
the way it's always been about
everything always like when you showed
up on television on good day you know
Good Morning America or on The Ed
Sullivan Show you didn't own that you
know you're more than welcome to be able
to go and build your own app and things
that nature I think you know how we got
connected with backstage you know an
investor and you guys are like I think
we're where that world is going is very
fascinating to me but I don't think it's
your crippled one do I think that if you
can own it and execute it there and have
everybody there like an email list like
your own website like your own app does
that happen we're upside for sure I
think there's a chicken and egg issue
though which is if nobody's there like
why do you go on snapchat a Facebook
because everybody's there and you want
to siphon I love how people are like oh
I'm doing all this stuff for Facebook no
no
Facebook's doing all this stuff for you
they've curated you know hundreds of
millions of people into one place that
give you a chance to be seen or heard so
I think there's a little bit of chicken
and egg thing I do think as you gain
more traction and have more leverage
that you're able to take a little bit
more control of your environment if you
choose to but I think both work and so
to me rented space is very comfortable
to me to me anywhere where there's
attention is a viable place for one to
speak to the world and achieve their
story outwardly and I would not be
crippled by doing either or both Jake I
couldn't have said that better yeah yeah
that naturally that wasn't ten thousand
hours of morning it was for you but let
me let me let our men
the island Erica says talk to us about
the importance of knowing your fans and
owning your own platform so much
importance I totally think that you need
to be able to connect with the people
who are paying for your music paying to
come to your live shows even not paying
just ripping off line and really loving
your music those are the people who
support your entire career if you can't
connect with them whether that's online
face to face that shows etc then you
have nothing how much time are you guys
spending and it's okay if it's a zero
I'm just curious how much time are you
spending actually engaging with your
fans on social because for me that
you'll scalable like you can't be in Des
Moines Iowa right now but if Susie says
I love your stuff you can't engage it
was such a big thing for me in my early
days but I do think that it's becoming
out of that I think people are spending
less time tonight the make it 36 months
ago engaging with fans I think it's a
little bit of a decline in Twitter I
think if you look at all the social
networks besides Twitter they're more
push content out Instagram snapchat
YouTube you push content out whereas
Twitter when it was in its prime was a
little bit more back and forth so I was
curious where do you work it doesn't
come natural to everybody you're doing
other things but where are you guys
right now with literally like making a
video being like thanks al or like
replying to like carrot in a snap or
engaging with a comment and Instagram
and actually replying to it tell the
truth cause I'm a double jab hey I call
you out if you [ __ ] me here in my
house um yeah I would say not as much as
we used it if you what you're going was
saying earlier about how you would spend
15 hours per ceiling yeah comment yes
about an event that happened when we
first started off Jake was saying you
know follow every fan like Jake you were
really you really encouraged those yeah
exactly and we used to I remember being
at the airport waiting line responding
to fans being in the car works for
spotting a fan and after a certain
period actually I felt it actually
really worked well for us as far as
building our social media fan base but I
felt like it's stifled my creativity
interesting and like living in not
really knowing when I live in the real
world in a way I felt like every moment
I had to wait or every moment I didn't
have to talk to someone every moment I
was sitting on the tables on my phone so
nowadays I actually practice just giving
myself an allotment of time and I feel
like our fan base is really
understanding of that because we've been
pretty vocal of that and interesting um
so I don't think they take it a tinker
personally but I think this five these
four aspects that's your only other
place yeah and I also feel like
spiritually I'm going one direction
where I want to spend less time online
yes business-wise I understand that's so
important to engage but that's why we
still have people like you know what
Jacob yeah I go through phases we just
released an EP a month ago I was online
the entire life pretty much just
responding to people consistently kind
of went down there left her there and I
probably spend a good three hours every
week maybe just responding to people
every Monday or every Friday I just sit
down everyone else respond where what
platforms Twitter mainly that's the only
other maybe pretty guys producing
content perception like I just want to
say as an artist it's really important
to have a marketing firm have management
have friends have feet I don't we have
people to help curate content week what
we do is we'll sit down we creates like
a meeting once a week hey look at all
these pictures the other fun pictures we
take in this is what we did here's what
we want to say about it I have someone
else kind of do that work on that and I
think I think I don't think that's a
Novartis statement I think it's great
that you have self-awareness to know
what works for you because I think for
certain artists they should be doing a
ton of that because it's what comes
natural to them a lot of my business
front contemporaries are like you're
running all these businesses like why
are you spending four hours a day
engage
like that's my natural state it's right
in my information from it's what I want
to do but I don't think that that's what
everybody should do I think I like
listening to the way you guys answered
what I like is I just think you guys are
figuring yourselves out and putting
yourself in the best position to succeed
and I think really that ultimately is
the main play I really do I think fans
crave an experience a story much more
than content much more than they crave
whether or not you're responding to them
I just Rizzo Brian I would I would
actually learn that me and yeah we're
like I'm completely and I have a lot of
data to support us believe that access
is the most valuable thing an artist can
L bring the table access meaning that
you're accessible some sort of exactly
right they show you someone I think an I
think you can touch a movement so like
you deal with a lot of brands if a brand
doesn't respond to a questions you want
for hours that's a problem but when
you're an artist your responsiveness oh
I see it right amazing I think you I
think that's for sure so first of all no
good marketing solves a ship product if
you guys engaged 24/7 with everybody but
your music sucks [ __ ] you would lose on
the flip side I do think that people
really underestimate I can promise you
right now your top 5,000 fans would [ __ ]
their pants if you replied to them on
snapchat I don't even know how did you
want to thank senator Coons today I
think that they actually know how this
would reply yeah well no no what I can
do this right now because we still the
Middle's of show that's now tell what
I'm gonna what I'm gonna do right now is
even more interesting
guys this is my snap guys make a
commitment to uh get serious about snap
oh god no I'm sorry I can please I'll
try okay the thing is yes about snapchat
the reason it's the one platform that I
do not use is because it's the one
you're not I said no
I'm listening to how do you how do you
do that Pamela Smith the same you guys
wondering your generation no no no no I
don't think that um its behavior right
that's a 10,000 hours you put in the
work you can do it I mean I think like
multitask like that pretend of nose I
think you multitask quite a bit I hope I
do
of course it's not like it's just what
we do let's move on Tom asks how do
girls get hooked up with JQ Dell how big
of an influence has it had on your
career high school yep
I graduated with Jake you know Jake was
in my cell what with it which science
class was about ecology knows all I know
is I've got is II got a Dean um and Jake
you were actually you want to talk about
your music career you were pursuing
being an artist and I was at all time
like the worst when you DJ talent II
drama actually why didn't I just say why
didn't you just put in $10,000 I did I
did we kind of here's the thing I gave
up on my 10,000 hours as a musician and
my second still got to tell him okay I
like that I thought Jake this is Wow
lady here's it thing I mean yeah I made
a pivot and said okay you were smart
because not everybody can do every year
that they had action in Bell V Howard I
believe if you put in the 10,000 hours
it can happen but you know I must say
you could be at performing at the
Grammys but you can it's possible to
have a hit record I believe that that
can happen because how a lot of anything
can happen well but it doesn't
consistently happen like like to me
that's the point which is like I'm just
lettuce was so fast well what Malcolm
said though Malcolm said you couldn't
find people that had put in the 10,000
hours that had it me
of course cuz their stories weren't
known but it was he was trying to find
them and he could find them I mean how
many hours have you put into revving oh
my gosh
exactly the bottom line is not 2009
close but like that's impossible like if
you suck [ __ ] at something and you put
in 10,000 hours you're not going to
become one of the great right yeah I was
a better marketer I mean there's an
enormous amounts of kids that play every
single kid that trying to become a
professional athlete that didn't become
a brush line fleet which is almost
everybody put in all the hours from
first grade to senior year and didn't
make it 10,000 I mean that's that's the
thing
look at that so when you say about the
math on 10,000 hours and I spent 1000
hours for my rap career or was that
$10,000 in the studio I was definitely
not 10,000 hours in the studio like
trying to be the best rap nobody well I
love Malcolm nobody can convince me that
like if that was true yeah then we
should tell every six-year-old right now
they fed every minute of your time on
the number one thing that you want to be
and you will become that and that is
absolute [ __ ] I think that that's
absolutely true so you think if I take a
first grader right now and say you're
going to become a world-class surfer and
that's to be what if he or she wants to
be then you think they'll become a
world-class server it's so tough I think
they'll find their career in surfing and
I think that's a that's a logical that
great decision for that and you're
saying that because you found your
career in the music industry yeah
whether or not you're trying to do a
genius so that guy before the first
question he was asking about like the
course we were immature when they want
to be the star
I you know now yeah when you were when
you were 11 like they I believed in that
more than I believed in myself so that I
turn that way because they have talent
yeah I think that I think that that's
the point I don't know I really mean
that because you understand where I'm
coming from where my energies coming
from right now we're living through the
greatest era of fake entrepreneurs and
every single person that is under 25 is
coming out of school there look I'm an
app founder I'm sure you talk to these
me that hello everybody you're [ __ ]
entrepreneur and they just think because
they've said it and they're going to put
in the time and effort like that
automatically makes them a successful
entrepreneur and I just and that's the
key which is you can be anything
do I believe if I put in 10,000 hours of
the surfing that I'm you consumer I sure
do do I think I can win the competitions
they haven't Hawaii no I do not I think
there's a secondary thing that has to
happen like look at the NBA like you
mentioned adapt what about the 12th man
on the heat right he's one of the best
300 basketball players in the world but
you know like and he's made it but what
about the person right after that the
person in the d-league that's making
tens of thousands of dollars that guy is
literally one of the 500 best fast
players in the world but hasn't won
hasn't made it by that Malcolm
categorization and then you have just
millions of people there's millions of
people they're trying to make EDM and
hip-hop music right this second and so
many of them can't succeed in the
marketplace because the talent is a
variable I really do believe that like I
just don't see how one doesn't
understand that there's so many people
that want it there's so many people that
put in those hours and so many things
especially in music and sports which are
very high glossy exciting things to be
in society like I don't know I'm
fascinated by the talent conversation
because I think it's a dangerous
conversation because I was picking and
prodding the reason I'm in a good mood
is you're talking a lot more now about
self-awareness I think a lot of kids
right now we're getting eighth place
trophies and they think they're good
enough and then the world hits them in
the face and that's why we have so much
depression and other things that people
don't
everybody wants a rah-rah everybody that
you can do it nobody understands that
when they don't do it what happens to
that kids psyche and I think part of
being a successful young person is you
get the opportunity to make those pivots
you get the opportunity to say okay I'm
in eighth place maybe I should become a
coach maybe I should yes my question
when you were getting the direction that
you can still do it you can still do it
when so few can then you start getting
into a place where we're selling a bill
of goods to the youth that isn't true
and you start dealing with what I think
the mental health issues that are not
being talked about where everybody all
of a sudden after 50 years of prosperity
in America thinks that they're going to
become Adele and LeBron and they don't
and then they're baffled and they yeah
do you think that when you talk about
like the 10,000 hour rule that the
people that are making it do you think
part of that the equation is
perseverance though is so good maybe
like you should have heard the song as
we wrote back in the day and let you in
tell these well write to this day and I
could have got that I could have hacked
out and said hey I'm supposing I don't
think there's a single person that's
successful that didn't put in the hard
work which is the reverse of the
conversation I just don't think if you
put in the hard work you can necessarily
be successful there's nobody that's
achieved what you've achieve or what
I've achieved that got there by accident
didn't put
the work how many entrepreneurs or
talented people have you met that have
put in the level of work that you've put
in to what you do to create all of this
amazing office by the way that haven't
made it at a significant level I don't
know a first of all nobody works safety
numbers day like I do but ah the punch
line is I know a lot of kids that have
been hustling for the last six or seven
years trying to build an hour on their
third business and they're never going
to make it a lot because they're so
meals they don't have to get their meals
they don't have probably you - word if I
didn't really get to the core of it they
don't have a skill to be a business
person that can make a business
successful the end there the kids on
American Idol who literally come think
they're Adele saying you only put in the
work though because it affected their
other third business a lot of them being
slow meals that they're kind of be a
true they're not let's go let's go into
a different place right are you telling
me that talent has no part of equation
well that's what you're saying huge but
I just want to know why generation you
know why do you want are those who
achieve tell I truly believe that and
there have been so many people in art
and like in our experience who have come
around that we may be men or even or
even understand I think people can break
through and get better do you think
everybody can do you think the majority
can know well then I think everybody
everybody has a unique talent though it
might not be music or sports days to
find it a part of being a successful
twenty-something is understanding how to
maneuver in times of change and
understand that you have to sometimes
pivot and how does any of those 20 year
olds are going to find success how many
20 many that's not to as many that are
studying the same same principles and
have the same values that you have last
question before I get really important
it plays like a much furnace I love it I
love I love another was I love it
because I love like first of all it's so
funny cuz I'm the most optimistic person
I know and I feel like I'm Debbie Downer
here I do think what's scaring me and
why I'm talking about it is I think the
pendulum swinging a little bit too much
to anybody can make it everybody can
make it just put in the work and I
believe in that but I think that that
maximizes what you have
I think the work will maximize what you
have I just don't think everybody has it
especially when you get into art when
you get into music and sports and things
of that nature
that adds a tough challenge last
question Chris asks how do you girls
stay so grounded in a fake world you
know big world
I don't know the people I surround
myself with are fake yes eimai oh so you
guys are grounded
exactly batshit crazy don't know if I
were to answer that question I would
also say family we are family for each
other obviously resistors and we're very
close with our family and nothing
happens
that doesn't slide by our dad or our mom
and they keep us in check and we keep
each other in check yeah and also not
feeling entitled like I think that's
something we've really surrounded by
especially in the dance music realm
there so many DJ's we have this entitled
bar line you can see al online ad in
person there's so much like subtext to
what you're saying right now it almost
is in sign it is like a hierarchy of
like who what kind of like value you
bring and why that's more valuable than
other careers or other realms in art and
I think back to what you even the first
question when you're saying what made
you pop off or yeah like like I've no I
actually never really felt like we
popped off I never really felt like we
made it and I don't think I think the
day I really feel like Cruella made it
is what I'm gonna lose that hunger I
think we have to constantly remind
ourselves to to understand our value and
our worth and to acknowledge our
achievements of artists but not to let
that hinder us from you know having that
hunger to work every day to go to the
studio every day to say yes to
opportunities is the second you start
saying I got uh no I'm good you know
what I mean
exactly or I'm too good yeah what do you
think for then for just about the game
right like what do you think I actually
want got you for another second right
like where is the current state of EDM
and your guy
penny like you know obviously was a
space that like I don't know eight years
ago nine years ago most people didn't
know about I still think there's a lot
of people who are watching over 40 50
year old marketing dudes that have no
idea what this space isn't they're going
to google it but obviously when you
start talking to a 35 and under demo in
America and obviously in Europe another
place that's been huge like everybody at
this point already knows that it's like
so interesting to look like it's really
to me the thing that is most followed
hip hop as a new genre that didn't
really exist before I don't I'm curious
for you guys who are much closer to it
like where is it its life cycle just
starting hitting an interesting time
like it's become dramatically more
mainstream than it was five six years
ago like what's your kind of point of
view on it I think it's plateaued I
think it's hit hit the climate actually
I don't think it's going anywhere
anytime soon
it's just branched off in so many
different directions there's so many
different subgenres there's new artists
coming through every day guys like
Skrillex and Diplo are doing a great job
of co-signing younger talent bringing
them up through the system and there's
the difference between it now and what
it was you know 15 years ago was how
much corporate back insurance I mean you
see it with the brands going all the
time and how badly they want to be
involved with these entities and the
biggest the biggest you know throwers of
festivals in the world these biggest
entertainment companies of the world
that puts so much money into making sure
that it's going to stay where it is
great keep our ladies it's hard for me
to comment on this because I do feel
like we've never quite belongs in the EP
well okay then so it's hard for me to
look at us as even still a part of it
even though I know that it's kind of one
foot in the door one out for us okay um
we've always tried to maintain our own
lane while still again keeping one oh
but in the EDM ownership I think that
that's probably a good thing for us
because like Jake said I agree I think
it's plateaued and we have this amazing
opportunity to take ourselves on a
completely different Lane and pave our
own way do our own thing yeah it's cold
um I just want to think like a lot of
what we're talking about when you're
talking about like depression
yeah these young entrepreneurs yes um
maybe feeling let down at the Carroll
achieve the success that they've been
hyped up to achieve what do you think
like our society to be a more and more
Fame obsessed society has to do with us
that especially with social media I
think uh yeah I think I think the whole
15 minutes of fame has become
everybody's famous to 15 people you know
you've got an entire generation of young
teens right now that take 45 minutes to
take a selfie because they want to get
the lighting right and a person in scrim
doesn't get enough likes to take it down
right away like peer pressure and like
you know like the way what I've never
been more obsessed with him still I have
a seven and four year old like
instilling self esteem into them is
everything because they're going to need
it really very big because the market is
going to push back on every one of their
flaws um yeah I think we're living
through a really really interesting time
I really do I think there's a lot of
things happening at once this is not a
very simple issue where it's just like
social media I think parents on 40
parents of my generation that grew up
during great times you know we're not
our parents are great parents great
grandparents generation where they
fought wars and the depression and
things that Asia we've had so much
prosperity that I think if you look at
every Empire that when things are good
for too long people become soft and I
think that's what's happening
I think we're soft and I think you know
coming from an immigrant DNA like you
guys were like it's easy
for me to see if like I just think we're
soft that I think that um and I think
that I don't want to add to it as a very
positive optimistic rah-rah crush if
anybody can do it guy I want to also at
least have the other part of the
equation which is of course hard work of
course talent and of course like look
there's so much going on in the world
right now I think we're all sensitive to
a lot of different things that are
happening like you never know when
prosperity can end it ends in a blanket
so I'm just I'm thankful for the way it
is I'm not gonna I'm not think kids
being stuck in their cell phones all day
is a bad thing I don't think it's
ruining them I think technology is
eating the world and I think it's gonna
be more of that I think that when you
guys first started doing shows to
compare to now if you think about phone
usage of your shows when you guys are
standing there I'm curious when you
think of like what's going on down there
because that's just their norm like I
love you you know that you guys see that
picture of like the 90 year old woman
that was in the crowd when the Pope came
and everybody took a photo and she
didn't and everybody made a big deal
about that you did did you see this yeah
so I and says you guys say it you see it
so it was a photo like six months ago
when the Pope came to the US I think
like that everybody made a big deal
about which is everybody's taking a
photo of it and she's just stamped she's
like ninety and she's just standing
there and everyone's like she's a hero
and literally I take a reverse feel like
I'm like I feel bad for her because
she's old and she probably already
forgot about that moment where is
everybody else recorded it and I know
it's under the age discrimination I know
of course at the inches cremation I'm
trying to make as soon as the joke I'm
sure she remembers it I have no idea she
is but I think that change is tough in
the same way that like like it stained
to music both hip-hop and EDM one foot
in one foot out both little Jean Rose
had nothing but haters in the beginning
saying that's not real music mm-hmm and
I just don't like when people impose
their thoughts like just because kids
are communicating this way doesn't mean
that Millennials are introverted I look
into all my old friends and when I say
gold I mean 35 year olds say that these
kids can't hold a real conversation
because we're having mirror meanwhile
these same kids spoke to the same six
people their entire childhood because
they didn't have the outlet to different
people different things
kids are much more whirling they know a
lot more and so I don't think anything
is bad I'm pretty much an optimist that
way but I am worried about depression
because I do think way more scary to me
than living a public life and fame
obsession is parents telling their kids
things that are realistic mm-hmm I do
think that like we have to train on our
generation to deal with adversity and I
don't think getting an eight a trophy I
do not think that if you come in [ __ ]
last place that your team should be
cheering and celebrated and given
trophies they should be looked at like
you guys suck [ __ ] you lost so if you
think that it isn't I really believe
that's healthy but the advice to the
entrepreneur to like to push through and
to these girls are going out of business
do you understand what's gonna happen so
tonight not to send anyone it's not an
opportunity event on to the next one of
course you to keep going people out
there kid going yes not personally
coming but if you are not self aware if
you kept rapping the man you would not
be as happy as you are to agree so now
go tell them to keep going when they
were too young you'll figure it out dude
that was the moment that's the bottom
line you understand because he keep
going keep evolving
yes but blindly going there I'm going to
be Eminem isn't gonna work but if you
don't do that you're never you'll never
figure out so like if I had in football
that time and energy into that I
wouldn't have understood that's our
favorite chord a so that's a very
everything then keep evolving and be
self-aware and understanding your
strengths and weaknesses to create the
next opportunity versus what people
normally hear when you hear keep going
which is if I just keep taking more
hours eventually I'm going to put this
on I guess I know that's all you did you
didn't keep just putting up songs I
didn't told you something else but if I
hadn't kept going if I would have
stopped those thousands and thousands of
times people told me I could do it but
please understand this conversation and
we look back at it you adjusted to a
different opportunity off those
learnings that is not what people that
you're like let's keep going then by
your definition but I'm telling you
right now that's not what people hear
what people hear keep going they think
you're going to break through and the
thing that they you know everybody wants
to be a famous singer a famous athlete
and a famous actor and if that person
keeps acting instead of becoming a
director which is maybe the skills that
they have they're going to lose so I
think what you
say we keep going stay focused we'll be
open to reinventing yourself along east
everywhere it's of my favorite part of
this it's what I jumped on earlier if
you actually know yourself you can win
so much more just this blind faith that
everybody's entitled to this level of
success is ludicrous because most people
don't want to work hard enough most
people don't have enough talent and the
math has proven that that's not the case
the bottom of the 1% the 1% earners in
America the top 1% earners the bottom of
that made $400,000 a year if you go talk
to every 15 to 22 year-old they don't
even conceive anything being short of a
millionaire of making a million dollars
a year but the data shows only 1% of our
us society make $400,000 for more and
that makes them one of the top 1% we
have not had the proper conversation for
every one of you guys there are 50,000
groups that didn't make it and it wasn't
because they gave up one year too early
they just weren't talented enough that's
what I believe
question of the dad jobs for my you guys
you guys get to ask a question of day
which is cool I'm curious to see where
you guys go with it you get to ask the
vaynernation any question will be
hundreds of answers on YouTube and
Facebook oh go get tasks yes oh my god I
feel like I kind of asked you no not me
you're asking the masses everybody would
just watch this wait yeah I'd like a
minute I guess that's good we don't know
some please that I wanted to ask you but
I guess I can ask everyone else because
if a lot of them are in the same boat as
you as a parent how much you raise your
children with or without social media or
technology in general you know would you
that would be just so what or with it if
they kept if you decided for them to
like have social media in their life
decided not to ban social media from the
household how what would your
child-rearing be like it what kind of
technology general I mean you see
one-year-old on an iPad you know I mean
ago she does bad I don't know I'm not a
parent I'm sure but you're a human I
don't wanna get this guy yeah I know it
when I see it comfortable I've seen I've
been in like to me airplane rest to her
airport restaurants where I've seen like
a parent on their iPhone and like a baby
with an iPad and like the toddler like
playing another game with Tyler playing
another game now what if I showed you
the world 18 years from now and the
entire ecosystem of relevance and being
able to even survive in it is predicated
on technology because that's the
evolution of man okay okay so now maybe
this is my like romantic point of view
like you said work what's the big deal
be relevant why is everyone so obsessed
with saying oh you're not relevant
anymore
oh you're trying to be relevant I really
so observe the development is contextual
the elementary relevant irrelevant is
you can't even communicate to your
grandchildren because they're only
willing to text you and miss your
granddaughter that's why we're into a
diet but I think it's important to adapt
but at the same time I think that at
least what I've seen from my generation
and younger is this obsession with being
relevant it's all based on like pop
culture as if like if you don't know
what's going on if you're not tweeting
about that's one our year one that's
never change easily combined to a high
school because you wanted to be popular
and I was just living under a rock I
don't know you're the hallway you're
more than welcome
I think you guys should find out right
now together album live on the rock I
think we're losing value and course
there's always a Twitter I don't want
that to my value to be based off of what
I know and pop culture what basketball
team is winning in first and though like
who performed know what award show like
but you don't have to and many people
don't but you also have first and that
same technology is why you're even
sitting here right now the information
that is built on top of the Internet
itself is the only reason I'm going to
be not the only reason you might have
have been lucky in an old-school music
environment that had somebody in LA
saying no no you
girls are going to make it like but
there's always pros and cons stimulus I
get that that's why I make em I'm an
extremely conflicted artist because the
very system that we're working within
it's also like I see myself going
opposite I think usually like I think I
think that's cool and I think you're in
full control and I think much like
anything even though we may disagree in
certain things in this episode and like
what people watch like that's what's
awesome like first of all it's going to
play out like I think humans have a good
track record of sticking around we've
been around for a long time we've
evolved go you know what you would get a
real kick out of go read the articles
written about the invention of the
television the invention of the phone
the invention of video games all of it
ruined us yeah I'm ruined exactly Zeldin
like um just so you know we were all
rightly writing a lot how do you asking
questions we'll keep debating them
you